[Music]
this is nature's publication record 150
years of interconnected research
represented by the majority of nature's
papers a snapshot of the ever-growing
web of collaboration and discovery that
is science each dot is a paper the color
represents the field yellow for Earth
and space science green for physics and
so on
two papers are connected if a third
references them both using these simple
rules scientists built the network paper
by paper let's start from the beginning
1869 these are the early days of science
publishing back then papers didn't exist
as they do today rather they took the
form of correspondence popping up
sporadically but over time things change
they start to cluster together into
disciplines communities emerge in 1986
the discovery of high-temperature
superconductors leads to a blossoming of
similar papers in nature shown here in
green it was a field which would
continue to grow throughout the 20th and
21st centuries
back to the 1930s now the two world wars
lead to an increase in nuclear physics
research as a nation's race to split the
atom and this too is reflected in
nature's publication record as nuclear
physics papers clustered together in the
30s and 40s and there that's a paper
putting forward a concept in genetics
called canalization it was published in
1942 but remained largely unsighted for
decades that is until the late 90s when
new discoveries led to it finding new
relevance each paper takes its place in
this network of nature but that's just
the beginning every discovery is built
on the work which precedes it and then
in turn forms the foundations of the
discoveries of the future and we can see
that - let's take Watson and Crick's
seminal paper on the structure of DNA as
an example here it is below it is every
paper that it referenced not just nature
papers every paper then every paper that
those papers referenced and so on above
it is all the papers that built their
work based on Watson and Crick's
discovery at the center are the most
highly cited papers orbited by those
with fewer connections by looking from
either end we can see the fields cluster
together let's look at the papers
referenced by Watson and Crick as well
as biomedical science there are
contributions from other fields
chemistry and physics feed into the
discovery of the double helix
after publication the picture looks
somewhat different the structure of DNA
formed a springboard the engineering and
technology research there are clusters
of mathematics papers even studies from
the humanities and Social Sciences every
paper has its own story its own unique
network and each of those networks
connects to others to form a whole every
paper in every field playing their part
in the global process of research and
discovery
over 150 years nature too has played its
own small part contributing its
publication record to the great
interconnected network of science
you
[Music]